do you still have those moments of anger
not anger no but no when i work out i'm
angry yeah that's true but i'm working
on [ __ ] fears i'm screaming sometimes
yeah what do you what do you
attribute that to um
my experience in life by experiencing
taking the toll
[Music]
looks like a cigar it is a cigar that
one in it
doesn't have tobacco that's gonna kill
me you do what you want i love doing
what i want i love you gym for that
okay we on the air everybody's ready
right
all right bring us in mike god damn we
need a bat a fan in here though
i'm gonna float out of here oh man come
on you're guys are crazy let's go
okay there's another episode of hot
boxing with mike tyson
i'm evan britt and we have a real
awesome guest here today
my buddy you know i mean sportscaster
extraordinaire they're great hall of
famer
jim gray what's up mike
been a long time with mike we've been
together a long time that's right
great to be here with you you guys have
known each other a long time yeah
i know mike since he was 16 how old are
you now i'm 52
that's a lot of years yeah that's a lot
of years we're coming up on
on 36 years oh god wow
think about that that was crazy it's
crazy we still
remember when i met you when when when
what day was that tell us
i met you well well you were you were
training in the catskills i met you
and then we had our first uh interview
back then but
we then had our first real long
conversation you may be 19 or 20 you
came into mateo's restaurant yeah
yeah remember that i think you were with
jimmy jacobs and yeah that was fun
don king was there yeah that was i
remember mateo was the best
oh in westwood yeah what's the best
remember maddie yeah
i remember oh man he would come by
introduce me to people and stuff
everybody was in there used to be a
restaurant on sunday nights and
i'll tell them about this oh my god
everybody sinatra was in there lucille
ball
sammy davis anybody bob hope
bob anybody is sitting there now davis
you're chilling out
it's incredible it was fun this is
westwood in l.a
yeah now david still there it's still
there it's on westwood and pico yeah
it's still there
still there wow it's changed hands
maddie died and uh
his wife jackie she sold it and uh
but it was that was saying
and they had a cleveland browns car
because art model was the owner of the
browns and
he used to be in there all the time so
they added a car cleveland brown's a
car on the train set that was just an
awesome place to be that was just really
at that time of my life you're
going in there seeing everybody bob
streisand and
seeing everybody like wow since you're a
kid you watch these guys on these late
night television
flip wills and all these guys like whoa
this is a trip they were all in there
johnny carson it was something it was
special that's pretty simple
but anyway we had our first real
conversation there he sat down at the
table
he was looking at the train the train
was going round and round and uh
i said hey mike and he had seen me on
television obviously and i had
interviewed him
sat down and we had a conversation i was
with my dad
and then mike so mike was maybe 19 or
20. not sure exactly
but every time i saw mike after that
until my dad died about five or six
years ago
every time i saw him the first thing
come out of mike's mouth didn't matter
where we were what fight we were doing
whether it was manchester or the mgm or
anything first thing he would say when
he saw me
how's your dad jerry you know
since you brought that up you know
i met jim but what i always know i knew
i always knew that um for my mom his
father was just the man
you know i mean all the um your father's
associates and everything
um marvin davis and all those guys you
know
your father was just a man you know and
everybody always told me about your
father he was the man don king was
saying he was the man everybody
just had great reverence for your father
well he was
he was a great man he really was and he
helped a lot of people and
uh tell us about him come on he gave me
my love of sports
and he gave me where was he where he
grew up at where was he in denver
yeah and he stayed in denver his whole
life and he would travel around and
do his work but you know he raised us in
denver and
my brothers were older than me so i got
to spend a lot of time with my dad
because my brothers were out of the
house by the time i was
you know old enough to you know really
be able to do things and and so forth so
we went to bronco games and
rockets and nuggets games and he would
take me down to the golden gloves
golden gloves was big in denver and
every christmas
my dad loves boxing my dad we used to go
to all the fights
and he would drive us by sonny liston's
house yeah sunny liston lived on monaco
avenue
not far from where we lived and grew up
and so we would go
every christmas go to see his lights and
hope to see him standing outside
he lived by stapleton airport which was
the old airport in denver
and we would go down there and and look
at that and he would take me to watch
ron lyle
spa or ron lyle's fights and uh
he just loved it and we would watch the
fights on television black and white and
uh bob dunphy and then howard cosell and
and so uh you know i was just uh exposed
uh to it at a young age that you know
all those
great great fighters and denver was you
know denver had a big boxing community
um so you know i kind of fell in love
with it and
and and it just brought me closer to my
dad not necessarily boxing
uh but uh just all the sports that uh
and i was a tennis player so he would
come to my matches and
and my mom and you know he just gave me
the ability to
do what i wanted to do and and and the
freedom
uh without interference uh but the but
the guidance and the love
uh you know that that's required to to
have a successful life
and so without that
you know without without pressing you or
pushing you into what to do he always
just told me you know
whatever you do work hard and do it with
integrity
and uh so um
you know we miss him he was my best
friend you know it's a
it's a tough you know everybody goes
through it everybody loses loved ones
uh and then when it happens to you uh
you lose your best friends and you've
lost
tremendous amount of people in your life
you know that they're irreplaceable
you look for it in other people but
there isn't another father
and there isn't another best friend and
there isn't people who are in your
circle that you really trust
that you can find it from even though
you try to gravitate to those people who
you think might
it's just not the same so um
was lucky to have had him for the first
uh whatever it was 54 years of my life
and my mom is still alive and she's
great so the good news is when i see my
mom i feel my dad
and she's still in denver and rolling
strong and
so tell me what do you think you met her
i want to know about more before what do
you think make your father so
influential
his honesty his integrity his principles
you know he grew up in a time you know
where
you know people didn't have much so they
helped each other
and he saw you know what his grandfather
did
in the community to help others who had
come over from europe
uh who you know and then my dad was a
naval reserve
for for the war and so you know they
knew
they knew that the times you know
required that you had to figure out how
to
help others who didn't have what you had
so
my my grandfather was my great
grandfather his grandfather
used to always tell them jerry if you
make a dime you give someone a penny
if you make a dollar you give someone 10
cents
if you make more than a hundred dollars
you better give somebody more than 10
so he figured out you know that it was a
uh
if if you ever became successful that
you had an obligation
that you that there was a requirement
morally
to do whatever you could
to help others so my dad was a very
philanthropic man he got involved in all
kinds of charities
how did he meet his friend how did he
meet his friends yeah
he's got marvin davis and all those guys
well my dad was a was an accountant
by trade that's what he did yeah he was
he was a and he had a certified public
accounting
but being an accountant just being an
accountant you know you get to know so
many people
he ended up doing the taxes for a lot of
people in in colorado
and so you know he became trusted that
you know he would handle people's
circumstances in in in in their
accounting and
and you know uh figuring out ways how
they could finance and and
and and do things and and you know being
responsible
uh to paying the government and also uh
you know
being able to fund some of the other
stuff so he was uh
he was just trusted how do you gain
trust why do you trust me
it's something you can't really you
can't really put your finger on you just
know it
our experience together correct so i
would know that joe was a scumbag
because
all in the journeys of where we traveled
so we met a lot of bad people
so it would be easy for me to identify
you as a bad person
right so that experience that he had
with others led them to
be able to know that he could facilitate
a relationship and be counted
on and be trusted and he wrote i must be
powerful stuff
he really he really wanted to trust you
he really was and uh
you know he was he was proud of all the
things that he was able to uh
to accomplish not only in business but
he was very proud of all the people that
he helped who couldn't help themselves
uh whether it was uh guys who who were
nameless
uh uh you know and and done anonymously
which he did a tremendous amount of
people for uh for people who
you know no one not his friends not even
his family i mean i had a guy come up to
me
at his funeral and he said to me
do you have a moment and i was just we
were just walking out of the funeral and
he said
can i talk to you for a moment i want to
tell you something about your dad that
you don't know
and i'm thinking what the [ __ ] this guy
going to tell me i got a brother or
something
another brother that i don't know i'm
thinking this goddamn guy why are you
going to tell me something about my dad
that i don't know right now and so i
kind of looked at him and i kind of kept
walking he said no it's important
i'm thinking oh god my heart you know
how your heart kind of sinks you ever
had somebody come up here absolutely and
you're thinking oh
god yeah when they serve you with some
papers
so he said to me he said to me you know
you your dad was involved in something
called the bridge foundation
at the university of denver i said yeah
he said he's a trustee and he helped
create the whole thing and he said yeah
and he said
there's tens of thousands of students
who've been educated because of your
dad's help
and they're all living much better lives
because
of what he was able to do and how he was
able to help them all
and what the program was is if you could
not afford
college and you came from i believe it
was denver public schools and you
couldn't afford it he would bridge the
gap
in other words if you needed a hundred
more dollars he'd give you a hundred
dollars if you needed a thousand he'd
give you a thousand
they created this whole foundation to
bridge the gap of what people could
afford
and what they couldn't afford so that
they could then be educated
and uh so we changed the lives of you
know
thousands of kids uh in the community
and he left the part of himself to be
able to help others for future
generations
so uh you know it's a it's it's
it's mind-boggling you know and that he
had the time and
and the inclination and the willingness
to do that and
all the other things that uh he did but
uh that one
i walked away from that guy and i felt
great but i wanted to i wanted to smack
him at first
how do you live up to something like
that you can't yeah you can't but it's a
great example
and you just um that's what you hope to
do in life
he always used to say to me if you can
help somebody help them
if you can't you hope they understand
so you try to do the best you can and um
you know as a great role model it's it's
hard to
you can't fill those shoes nobody can
but you can try and do your best
and the great example that he and my mom
have set
and uh just the honesty and decency
and integrity and i'm glad you got to
know him a little bit
and uh what you said to me at the hall
of fame uh again
last year you know that made me cry
before we started
when you started to cry that was uh
i wasn't expecting that but
i can't tell you how much that meant to
me because you could go to a place that
i wasn't going to go
you know i wasn't going to take the
people there and he did
that was a great moment
thank you brother you know um
just going going with this journey in
life with you know i mean knowing you as
a human being a person knowing what you
experienced
with you know just [ __ ] from people
from [ __ ] with me and
[ __ ] with um pete rose and all that [ __ ]
and um
the only thing that i i realized
you experienced what i experienced we
never gave up
no matter what anybody said to us they
try to break our spirits
you know destroy how we felt about
ourselves our confidence you just never
gave up in life
like that
you know i was kind of fortunate just in
my own brain
to think that you know when people have
opinions they're entitled to their
opinions
and if we're going to dish it out we
should be able to take it
so when people give you a hard time even
when they don't have all the facts
you got to correct the facts but
opinions are okay
everybody has an opinion and that
opinion even if you disagree with it
doesn't mean that they can't have it but
it doesn't mean that you have to believe
it so who am i going to believe
some guy who doesn't know me some guy
who
who who for whatever the reason has
venom or anger or jealous or petty or
by the way sometimes the criticism's
correct and when the criticism's correct
you got to do your best
to take it to heart and change i mean
if somebody says something about you and
you know it's true
don't fight it fix it
right 100 yeah so sometimes sometimes
you just have to fix it
sometimes you got to take your medicine
when you're wrong and when you're not
wrong
well i just disregard it because what
does it matter what they think
does it matter to you what somebody
thinks that doesn't know you it matters
to me when my wife's mad at me
matters to me when you're mad at me
matters to me when people who know me
and care about me
when they're pissed off i better look at
myself and and get it right
hey what do you think about this um you
know well he thinks that i was
speaking earlier i took this ancient
drug
the tmd um explained to um generally dmt
dmt 5dmt 5meo 5meo
dmt yeah i don't know what that is it's
a it's a hallucinogenic some so to speak
isn't it yeah
it's entheogenic so it it helps people
dealing with depression
anxiety addiction cancer
you experience an ego death is it
ignorance
it's legal in ceremonial medicinal
settings
and you can go to legal in the united
states yeah
um i don't know maybe maybe not depend
right depend if it's an indian
reservation or something
to that effect okay so where are we
going with this what does this guy do
listen this is going to be so
interesting that's why i'm saying that
um right that's i experienced with this
um
how do we call it what do we call it
this ancient ancient medicine medicine
and man um and so i'm thinking about
doing this because i'm not worried about
doing drugs the guys explain this is a
magic drug it's a guard monocle and
stuff
and i'm saying so really i'm i'm hiring
cocaine so yeah let me see what you got
okay let me see what the [ __ ] you got
okay so i'm going back the guy said not
now let's finish the conversation
because i'm interviewing him so he's
talking about this and i thought i can't
wait you're so full of [ __ ]
i'm telling you you can't do this and so
i go in there right
and i smoke and man i just i said i'm
dead
holy [ __ ] the first time i said i'm dead
these people killed me holy [ __ ]
where is this what country um it's close
by
it's close by right this guy dr jerry
comes from mexico
he's a shaman he's performed thousands
of these ceremonies
don't worry about it and then oh i see
you won't believe this you gotta see
this
i've been everywhere with you i'm not
gonna not believe anything because i've
seen it all every time i said i can't
believe it
okay i took this drug i disintegrated i
have no longer a physical being i'm just
all spiritual being there's nothing
physical about me and i'm just
i'm just gone and i'm dying and um it's
over
everything is um
marginalized it's just it's and um
i'm i'm happy with that no one's in my
life no wonder you got all these
millions of people watching this
no some crazy [ __ ] i can't know so i
said to all of us so what's the question
all of a sudden i
ask god i just ask god i want power i
want power and also and i
disintegrated that must have been a hell
of a trip
oh man the mic is really
it's it seems like my first
trip i did it five times mike has been
better slow down buddy
no way no way there's no way i'm seeing
i'm i'm excited this guy is so much more
than god
when i first met this guy six months ago
he was doing well but he had a lot
on him you know obviously he's been
through hell and back well when you
alter all these chemicals in your brain
and you start taking this stuff
yeah this is gonna be a little lighter
yes this is crazy
be careful no watch out what you're
doing i'm not afraid
okay absolutely afraid all right
definite stuff is not even
his existence i don't even know how to
respond to that so
well let's go on to the next one okay
you've interviewed this guy a lot yeah
right uh-huh is it funny to be on the
other side of the
the mic no i would like i did a podcast
with him a year too
much yeah yeah i did that one and
you know i've had we've hung out
together in in you know just
where you know we just shared life's
experiences and
we've been all over the world together
yeah so i mean you know
we have a relationship we have a
friendship
i trust mike and like i said at the hall
of fame last year without mike
you know i wouldn't be where i am today
he's been an important part of my career
uh he's he's trusted me
and um in many ways
standing next to mike you know along
with others along the way
you know made me famous if that's the
right word
you know you really are famous jim gray
well i don't know about that i don't
even
i don't really i don't like that word
but because of all of the attention that
mike you
reckon all of his fame when you're
standing next to him
and he's doing all this stuff and he's
you know said his back is broken and
he's bitten some guy's ear off and he's
won championships and he's the youngest
heavyweight ever it's not just the
the you know the crazy stuff but it's
the
immortal stuff for boxing and for sports
that he accomplished
you know you get the benefit of that
you get you get you derive all of the
accolades that he is accepting
because you're standing there next to
him talking so you you get a lot of
great benefits and i've been able to
benefit by having been
able to interview mike at all of these
times when the public
when he had the public's attention and
not only was it
you know in this country but it was
worldwide and and
and you know his greatness all of us at
showtime
all of us in boxing he elevated all of
that
so i've always been grateful to mike and
so so
you know what was that favorite fight
like you know what was the excitement
like you know i couldn't enjoy
like crazy like the big i beat up frank
warren
is skeptical am i gonna go to prison
after the fight
what's gonna happen and then the fight's
over quick and what the hell are you
thinking what do you guys say the fight
is [ __ ] over
i'm gonna put that story when i if if i
ever write my book i'm gonna put that
story in the book i'm not gonna put it
on this podcast
i'm gonna put that story in the in the
book but uh
oh [ __ ] but i mean let me tell you
something if i really
you know if i really sat here and
thought about it you could do
a book on mike of everything and he's
done his st he's done his story yeah
he's done uh undisputed and let me tell
you something
he's left a lot of [ __ ] out of this yeah
volumes
a lot of material here volume and i
don't know
if it's because it didn't rank on top or
if it's because he didn't want that
exposed or if he's saving it all for the
next chapter and the next chapter in the
next chapter but let me tell you
something
every time you said i can't believe what
i just saw
or i can't believe that we just
experienced it something else happened
and here we go again fine what do you
like being on the plane that wonder
what's gonna happen next right now i met
this fight i never knew
you never knew and you still don't know
i mean you still don't
you know it's a journey yeah and it is
and it's
it's you know what am i just going to
throw podcasts what am i doing a podcast
i thought this stuff was for weirdos at
first
everybody was a podcasting on their
phones and stuff and on youtube
are you on your phone all the time are
you one of these no i don't know only
people the only person i call this
my kids and my wife
don't have me this company has me now
really so you don't get on the telephone
no no no i don't leave anybody i'm never
out of my wife's
children's site for more than a couple
of hours how you've
have you figured out how not to be
addicted to the phone like everybody
else everybody i want is
hands distance you know my children my
wife
my mother-in-law my father-in-law uh my
friends i come to work with them
we're all in distance i know everything
i want is
relatively close and let's go back to
the people who who you began your life
with
are any of them in your life no i just i
don't know what they're doing in their
life but nothing
you don't ever see them they know i'm
rory and john horn
never i don't mean them uh uh uh
teddy no kevin no
any of cusses people
oh yeah tom patty tom patty okay and how
about
jacob's family or the caitlyn family i
don't even see those guys never saw
those guys don
king's family no i called don the other
day used to say i apologize
you did yeah what'd he say
dumb don's a good man daniels don't get
it you know
i don't know i don't know dawn probably
thought i was trying to set him up on
the phone or something
i don't know he's he's very protective
he was skeptical he was very skeptical
he wasn't he
you know and after anyone and then i
thought he he may believe that i was
being sincere he said hey you're really
a good person you know i say well thank
you
you know thank you that was good you
called yeah but he caused that he was
very protective huh
what caused that i don't know because i
had a really nasty feeling in my
my body for throwing that water in his
face the last time i saw him
that was what that was that was the hall
of fame yeah i feel so
sickening about that because i was
watching youtube and used youtube
shoulders and shoulders
and us wow and i didn't feel good about
that i didn't like the way that picture
looked
so i called and apologized and stuff
well maybe that
wow that's awesome mike yeah okay good
i shouldn't be doing the [ __ ] like that
i've been doing i've been to too much
[ __ ] in my life to be throwing
waters in people's face like i'm a tough
guy
all that tough guy stuff got me in so
much trouble i remember my thing i was a
tough guy and i got me all that trouble
oh man god
jim what was it like getting in the ring
after this guy
fought to interview him i don't know
what the hell i'm gonna say he's like
breaking
fire dude he's like an unchained tiger
you know i'm gonna say
you know it's funny he didn't know what
he was going to say
but he always was respectful to me and
he was any any
of the position so
you know he never got nasty with me he
never got
angry with me one time he threatened to
kill me i did i'm sorry
he tried to kill me and don king he
threatened to kill me and don king and
and he said i'll kill you and i'll kill
don king he was mad at don
and he said and i s and i kind of looked
at him and 45 seconds later
he kissed me on my cheek oh my god and
it was far more disturbing that he
kissed me
than it was that he threatened to kill
me so i mean
other than that one 45 second thing
he was he was on time
courteous to me and the people at
showtime um
even in his craziest moments he never
lashed out at any of us that i can
remember
but then i wanted to kill you in no i
remember i wanted to kill you and don
king
i think he just said it because it was
an easy way to get to don oh
i'll kill you and don was standing
behind us oh
no why did you i don't know why you said
it what were you mad at him about oh no
was that after you'd thrown him out of
the car or kicked him out of the car or
whatever
i have no idea man no idea
do you remember all this stuff i
remember a few things yeah a few things
i remember being in miami
and um we're driving down what is that
the 10 to miami what is that in miami
305 no it's going it's going towards um
west palm beach
i don't know miami i don't know miami i
got to 20 to 10 i don't know something
it's that freeway that's always busy
yeah yeah before the turnpike we're
driving on
on the tournament and next thing you
know i just freaked out and i
kicked the guy and as soon as i kicked
him in the back of his head he puts on a
break and we stop in the middle of the
street and i'm just beating him in the
car i'm trying
yeah i'm trying to get um i'm trying to
get the girl in the front seat it's a
friend of mine to hold him so i can get
in the front seat with him because i
want to get him in the front
where he can't run like i'm in the back
and i can't get him the way i want to
because
i'm in back of him and i'm in the car so
i wanted to get out and so
i told her to hold him so as soon as i
let him go he
got the car right he got the car so i
tried to run
oh man gosh this was on the highway
yeah and you just left him on the
highway no
no he ran the car so i tried to run the
car so he did another back
turn and got back in the front and drove
off and left me
oh he love you that's me on the highway
yeah
oh but no no no check this out all right
i'm on the highway right i'm on the
highway so when he gets down there he
gets his real fault so he lets
the people who i was with my girlfriend
and my other thing he left them out the
car and they're walking up the highway
where cars are coming down
and they're walking up the highway while
they come to get me and so
one of his security guys in the roads
where he comes he thinks that we're
we're stuck on the road so he pulls over
and i'm mad because he's throwing
security i
give him a shot wow out
cars are coming the police car comes a
police closer and the car is out the
guy's shoes
and the cop picks up me i have cocaine i
have marijuana i have it in a box and my
girlfriend is holding right
the guy gets this and the cop puts us in
the car me
jackie lose and myself he puts it in the
car drives us to a hotel said are you
okay mr titan thank you very much
officer and lisa's up there have cocaine
in the bucket i have marijuana box a big
box right there oh my [ __ ] brick of
cocaine i got [ __ ] marijuana
everything in there
and um are you okay mr toad yeah we went
to my hotel room and everything
i'm stuck on the highway i should be in
handcuffs i want to hide when somebody's
all cold on the highway
he should put me in cause we should be
in the cop car
and we should be gone but the guy put us
in um the car took us to our hotel
and then he asked you why he was out
there excuse me he didn't ask you
he didn't ask me [ __ ]
i would still my heart was beeping the
girl's heart would be i'm ready
i'm thinking he's taking us to the
police station he took him right to our
hotel
wow that's amazing to convince our host
i couldn't even believe i you know i
can't believe it he didn't say a word it
drove us
and we're holding the drugs in the boxes
he was so stoked and he's
just took us in his okay mr titan yes
sir thank you officer
were you the heavyweight champion at the
time no no it was my laugh i didn't have
no money i was broke
i was i was destitute you know
did what he ever did to me and i was i
don't even know what i was doing out
there now let me ask you a question what
i wanna i wanna ask you a question what
did you do with all that money
hey i just gave a lot of it away i had a
lot of fun and
[ __ ] i did what i wanted to do i had a
lot of fun
um when i was a kid i just had a really
good time i was all over the world i was
in
sancho pay doing oh forget it with
awesome people wealthy
uh we just it was almost um it was
almost so bad it felt so good it felt
wrong
you know you're so wrong you're so wrong
to have all this ecstasy have all this
sensation have all this fun
and all this wealth it just didn't still
felt wrong but it was awesome
do you miss it no no it's going to
happen again but not the way it happened
last time you know so
i always was amazed i guess you're
supposed to ask the question but i
always was amazed
that that you haven't had regret
for that portion no you may you may have
regret in other things that you've done
and and feel bad and apologized or or
whatever but
for the way you live your life with that
money no i don't have no regrets
but maybe some but no as i got older i
say no because
when i was younger i said maybe i should
have regrets you know
but i should be good because my life
should be it should be different than it
is now
but it is it's the way it's supposed to
be now because it's prepared for grander
things
now that i'm in the stage of being able
to understand them and handle them
before i'm surprised i'm not dead for
the way i lived my life
you know what i mean i'm surprised at
how disrespectful i was you know during
that time thinking that i was god
you know i mean i had some tough friends
so if you don't agree with me you're
gonna be in some trouble
you won't go out with me all right your
boyfriend's in trouble now
just you know i mean it's interesting
because i've heard you say that mike
and then you know jim talks about how
respectful you were
to have been to him and to his father
and i've heard that all the time and i
see you
act and you have a ton of respect that's
awesome humility you know i learned that
from cuss too but this is how i was
gonna be
i'm gonna kiss the ring that's right
you're the man i'm gonna kiss the ring
but the people below me they're gonna
kiss my ring too
the old mic right there you guys there
we go i hear that emotion sure
no but it's not it's not about yeah
totally that wouldn't make sense
it was never about that but that's the
way i was raised you know you kiss the
ring but they're gonna kiss yours too
one day
you know but that was all ridiculous
when i took the toll what i realized and
understood about the toll
we all bowing down to god we're all the
strongest the post powerful the riches
the weakest we're all gonna battle under
god or something's bigger than us a
higher power
why why do you have a tattoo of days of
grace and arthur ashe
and and chairman mao i just i'm just
very fascinated with both them i thought
they were awesome individuals and stuff
i really um when i was in prison i
really wanted i almost
got um it was almost like a hypnotic
effect they had on me when i was in
prison
in what way on how to how to better
myself and strengthen myself for revenge
against myself
you want to decide against society yeah
society that put me in here
and lied on me but it was really a
blessing in disguise
you know because i started to learn who
i could really be
not who i wanted to be but who i could
be at that particular stage of my life
and what did you learn huh what was it
that you learned from them
that i learned that um we all going to
make mistakes in life
but when we make those mistakes we will
allow those mistakes become blueprints
to a bigger
a bigger part of our success in our life
and in civilization
so you were in the right place at the
right time for the wrong reason
absolutely there's no doubt about it
i think if i didn't go to prison i would
have aids or something
want to explain that yes these people
were really my
my friends were dying they're getting
sick and dying you know reckless
lifestyle reckless sexual appetites
and i was on that same wagon with them
so if i didn't get that three years i
would have probably been
in a lot of trouble
yeah wow
and jail pulled you out of that yeah big
time
i was absolute um slave to sensation
when i was a young kid when i was
fighting
before i went to prison i was just
slavish it felt good i did it
no matter what it was or what it was
so whether it was sex or drugs or
hitting somebody in the head whatever
made
anything that felt good being
disrespectful
it was if it felt good i did it
and how did prison break that just the
inability to have freedom
no i wanted to be in control of myself i
just wanted to revenge i
didn't understand i thought going to
prison i was i thought i was
i thought it was the [ __ ]
alexander dumas who was this guy
he wrote the book about the guy who's
the guy that went to prison camera money
chris
yeah i was reading that i thought that
was that guy am i a [ __ ] idiot
to believe that this was that kind of
harsh punishment i thought that
this was the worst thing could happen to
a human being i only did three [ __ ]
years of my life
and i had a ball in prison i had a
girlfriend
i got a pregnant prison i was living a
life in prison
how did you do that i just it's just it
was meant to be
i was mike tyson anybody gave me what i
want and i feel like a dick even talking
like i'm some tough guy
or some cool guy was just a pig
who brought you the women they worked
there
they're my teachers
and did she have the child no
i told you there's a lot of chapters in
there there's a lot of layers
mike when's the book coming out no not
about no book it's just that um
no this real life that was something
that was just real that was just real
life i was a savage i wanted to survive
i thought everything i needed to survive
i need this to survive i couldn't
you know i'm surprised i wasn't getting
hiding because in my mind i wasn't
i couldn't i couldn't succeed and
survive i did drugs and got high
so i didn't get high in prison how many
people would you say have that
experience in jail you describe jail as
being
a good experience i don't know i'm sure
listen um i didn't want to leave when i
left
why because i was secure i was safe
safe from yourself safe from
society safe from both both
so was there a judgment that was there
uh
was it a tough um a reacclamation
um big time big time
big time yeah i really didn't know what
i was doing when i came out of prison
i didn't know what the [ __ ] i was doing
it's always fascinating to talk to mike
i'm i'm
i have so much podcast i have something
going on everywhere i had so much
[ __ ]
vin vindictiveness venom in me i wanted
to prevent that from somebody you still
have
something still hearing me i hear the
old mic no but they didn't do anything i
just think that someone did something to
me because i thought that shouldn't have
happened to me
even though i took it as experienced the
best experience of my life i still feel
like it was
somebody did this to me instead of
looking at this was your best experience
to find out more about you
that you still nothing that you think is
something even at my the worst thing
with the worst the bottomless i can be
you know me i might see a [ __ ] mirror
and say wow
i'm good looking i can brush my [ __ ]
hair
and my ego will always come up some kind
of way i don't care how i try to crush
it
do you understand what i'm trying to say
absolutely yeah do you still have those
moments of anger not anger no
but no when i work out i'm angry yeah
that's true but i'm working on [ __ ]
fears i'm screaming sometimes
yeah what do you what do you
attribute that to um
my experience in life my experience in
taking the toad
you know i might scream i'm a [ __ ]
guard and then say excuse me i'm so
sorry i said that god
this toad thing needs more examination
but the toad thing didn't come into your
life until recently so yeah
the anger's been there all year how old
53 years
yeah but but it's not towards anybody
there's no physical being
that caused my anger nothing from a
physical perspective not a human being
anything i can name
anything that breathes doesn't cause my
anger
it's all internal all internal yeah
and how would you describe yourself the
internal equilibrium of mike tyson these
days
i i like forgiveness from mike tyson
yeah
you're trying to forgive yourself yes
have you
succeeded in some aspects yeah there's a
certain part of me i don't like myself
and think i should punish more
punish yourself more yeah that you had
too much of a [ __ ] good time
so you feel guilty about yourself
sometimes yeah
sometimes and how do you how are you
ever going to reconcile that
hey that's not me to find out it just
happens you know
it just happens well if you don't have
any control of that path
if there's no if there's no way of
knowing what
the next step in the journey is if
there's no thought process and you're
just reacting
well my reaction did pretty good i'm
doing pretty good with reaction you know
because it's not meant for me to think
you know it's my life that
i have nothing to do with my life has
nothing to do with me
my actions have nothing to do with my
life because my life is on a divine
path has nothing to do you're not in
control of yourself
excuse me so you're not in control of
yourself or you are not
from a divine perspective no from an
action
perspective absolutely that's only only
be controlled on me
and be um concerned with my actions
nothing else
truly exists in that that particular
realm
what do you think jim mike always makes
me think
no i'm just no i mean i have to i yeah
you
when i look at my wife and i think about
the fact that um
this is this is um this is not actually
my wife this is um
this is god's creation and i have no
control over that
there's no way i can ever control that
that's a powerful realization with your
spouse the fear that i can't that i
can't have that that one day i may lose
that
from health reason the death reasons of
its reasons i don't understand why
and that could be a possibility that
could be my biggest fear and i have to
look at that as this
is god's will
let's talk about flip i spoke to
somebody about flip
two days ago i spoke to somebody about
tell everybody who flipped was
flip listen flip with this guy that had
this is really existing
flipped with this guy that had a lot of
um influential
pulling all the hotels and this is the
age
listen this is what i found out recently
i had five thousand tickets to
everything yeah
he was something wow this guy was
dressed impeccably
black guy yeah i mean this guy was a
tall guy
long beautiful baby blue one day royal
blue the next day he had
beautiful green hat you don't see people
like this they don't make people like
this no more these guys have written out
of history man you can't believe that he
was at every fight
all these fights yeah ali ferns he's
always asking me if i want tickets to
any of the concerts
sinatra andy williams this guy had
everything and he would sit where would
he sit
in the in the in the goddamn hotel the
front bar
caesar yeah everything was i mean john
but everybody came to see flip really
everybody flipped new joe lewis too
remember joel lewis used to be i wasn't
around when joe lewis was the guy
oh joe joe joe used to be in caesars and
he would
he was a greeter yeah yeah what was that
like seeing
him every day will your father tell you
about him it was great
because he was an american hero he was
an international treasure
and then you'd see him and he'd be
talking to these people you know
caesar's
you know the government uh had
taken a lot of his money he hadn't paid
his taxes or they were after him for
whatever the reason
and uh so it was kind of sad that here
was this great
american hero and he was shaking hands
with everybody in the casino so it was
but he was pleasant
you know he was happy with his you know
he was he was very nice i mean you know
i remember with my dad i was just a
little boy
my dad and you know we went back and you
know it's not like youtube or anything
if you wanted to find out about somebody
you had to get the encyclopedia or you
looked at the library
physical work so it wasn't like there
was just film sitting around of joe
lewis you had to go search and seek this
stuff out
and so he taught me about him and you
know and so it was you know
it was like you became in awe and then
you'd see him the next time and you had
that history now in your head because
you'd been taught about him and um
he was great but i'm telling you he had
a crowd around him
everybody wanted to say hello to joe
everybody wanted to say hello to joe
but everybody went to flip to get
something done
listen joe lewis set a new um standard
you know because now people do that for
a living
meet and greet we do that for a living
you know i think people become
millionaires meeting and greeting people
that
normally would have been bummed would
have been sleeping in their cars or what
are you
talking about the memorabilia age now
the autograph
joe lewis would have been holy moly
when did he die i forget when he died
listen no he died the day
that we home fought cooney um no trouble
burbank 81 82 yeah so i said early 80s
yeah yeah oh wow
yeah but he this guy was something but
wouldn't flip die
he had to die in the late 80s and 90s
wait wait he wasn't around for the tyson
holyfield he went i don't think he's
around for that stuff
yeah [ __ ] yeah when when the fights left
caesar's he didn't see him much anymore
we had fun back then jen there's a lot
of stuff what were you guys doing when
you guys were all on the plane all the
reporters on the plane together
you know i used to go to fights early
and you know you
used to come early every man he was at
all your fights too who's that
john madden used to come in on the bus
and we would sit remember that
really oh yeah it's caesar's john would
come on tuesday said john john used to
have all of the close circuit fights for
the oakland area he was like the
distributor so he would get all the
fights
to deliver to the fans and and john
loved boxing i mean john's a huge he
still watches the fights to this day
still text me and yeah
talk to me about it anyway hi man so
john
you remember there used to be that
little elevator and that glass
thing that went up and seizes right
before he went out of the pool i forget
what the name of that i remember
yeah you go out to the pool and there
was this little bench right there and
madden used to sit there
on that bench and he come in on tuesday
we would then gil clancy would come by
and tim ryan would come by
and dick young and all the young
man all these riders would come you know
come by
and sit down and talk to madden and he
would just kind of hold court there and
he would sit and you know he was a super
bowl winning
coach and he was in his you know
beginning of his broadcasting career and
they would send him like for cbs sports
spectacular to interview the fighters
before the fights
so you know he would have ray leonard on
or he would have haggler on or hearns or
duran or whoever it was whitaker
you know any of those guys are all those
old guys that used to fight you know on
on cbs
and uh or before their their close
circuit fights
so i used to sit there with john all
week because we'd be the only people
that would get there on tuesday
you know i'd get there early to do you
know because top rank it hired me uh
bob aaron had hired me to do you know
all of his satellite interviews and
done then don hired me to do all that uh
all these uh interviews so
i would hang out with john madden he
became a dear dear friend and i
love john and john was brilliant he's
brilliant he's a genius
he was a genius about people a genius
about real estate
genius about football and he became the
most popular figure in the history of
professional football you know
madden madden the game now today crazy
is you know it's it not only did he win
uh
more games uh he won he won more games
to 100 he was
the the youngest coach to win 100 games
first then he won a super bowl
uh with the raiders and then he you know
had this incredible broadcasting career
he won
like 25 or 30 m he's the best
broadcaster forever
i mean yeah and then he created a madden
game so but he'd love boxing
and we used to talk about you all the
time oh my god honestly is mike tyson
crazy
what do you think mike no he john had
respect
john had deep respect for athletic
ability
really oh my god and he he he was
he was enamored by it he was uh
he thought you know he thought that the
guys that put in the work
that rose to the top step of the victory
platform
were guys who earned their way that you
couldn't [ __ ] that
you know you could [ __ ] in life and
you could make a team
and you could get on television and not
know your stuff
you know you could and madden would
always say that guy's a [ __ ] that
guy's a [ __ ]
but then when they when champions and
and and true great players and great
athletes
he was he was really had tremendous
admiration and respect
and john's still doing good john's up in
oakland
pleasanton nice coach madden yeah he
retired and he's one of the only two
people i know
in my life that walked away when he was
on top
in television only only two people quit
television otherwise television quits
you
yeah johnny carson and john madden left
while they still had a lot left in them
i'm surprised you never met coach matt
um i did an interview with him a couple
of times
i've never seen the interview i did with
him yeah okay good so yeah you know
that's cool yeah jim were you
um was your line through journalism
were you really did you as a kid you
wanted to follow that were you
interested in
being a sports writer like how did you
come yeah how are you getting involved
in this i love sports
and i was a tennis player and played
tennis in high school and
were city champions and so forth in uh
in denver growing up and i loved i loved
sports and playing sports and watching
sports
and so when i was a freshman summer
freshman college going
to i went down to the abc
station in denver and asked for an
internship or a job and they didn't have
anything
and they said if you get into school
college you'll get come back and try for
an internship so i went
to college and the first day i was on
campus i saw the man who i interviewed
with he said go over to the journalism
school and try and get an internship so
i got an internship
i was there for a month or two and they
were converting from film to videotape
so all the guys who were in the union
for the film took the buyout
so they hired me
and i got hired as a videotape editor
nobody knew how to videotape editors
they were i was 17 or 18 years old so
they were teaching every you know see
yeah that's good so they paid me a lot
of money paid me like twenty five
thousand dollars
when i was seventeen years old that's
crazy
i thought that was i thought that was
more money than i'd ever have so
i was able to buy my car it was a toyota
corolla
and that cost like 1700 and then i
bought beer for everybody
you know in the dorm i'd get a cake for
them every week
and i still had 25 22 000 after that you
know so
so anyway one day i was in my edit booth
i was editing a red miller was the head
coach of the denver broncos i was
editing the red miller show at 7 30 in
the morning
and the lady who was the head of the
bureau for assignments came running she
says you know
you know some you know something about
sports don't you and i said yeah a
little bit
she said muhammad ali's at the airport
he took an earlier plane he's two and a
half hours early
go out and interview him because back
then there were no cell phones
there was no beepers there were no
computers no no nobody had if you did
not answer your home telephone they
couldn't find you right
so they couldn't find the anchorman they
couldn't find the lead sports guy they
couldn't find any of the report they
couldn't get it
nobody's answering their phone they were
sleeping they were in the shower their
breakfast no god knows where they were
no pages back then
nothing so so i ran into the weather
man's office took his coat and tie
didn't fit it was a little itty bitty
guy named stormy and the sport coat came
up to here
so i took it off but i took his shirt
and his tie and i went out and
interviewed ali
oh my god ali was coming to town he was
going to talk he was talking about
his fight with sphinx was coming up and
then he was going to fight a guy named
lyle alzado who was a denver broncos
yes in an exhibition after the sphinx
fight that's right
so i interviewed him he gave me 45
minutes he was great
at the airport um he was just he was
just wonderful he was patient
he was nice he was funny he was
thoughtful he was all those things he
called me the
the local young howard cosell so anyway
so i took the interview back
and was going to edit myself out of you
know they weren't going to put me on the
air i was you know i wasn't on the air
so the head of the bureau came in there
they had a news director a guy named
roger ogden
and he looked at this and i don't think
this guy even knew my name you know he
didn't even know my name said
you interviewed i'll lead it i said yeah
he said let me see it showed him all 45
minutes
he said let me see that again so he
spent an hour and a half with me
and he looked at me and he said
we're going to put you and this on the
air
it's barely adequate
so i tell everybody i've been barely
adequate ever since
so that so so abc
saw the people there at the station saw
that ollie took a liking to me for
whatever the reason so they then sent me
to all of his fights to do an interview
well then
bob aaron saw that wow and he hired me
don king saw that and he hired me so i
worked for top ranking for king vision
you know top ranked first you know doing
all these interviews before the fights
with all the fighters and then
after the fights and then they would put
them up you know on these satellites in
the early advent of satellites and
all everybody would take them down and
use these interviews and it would help
them
you know promote their the early days of
pay-per-view was closed circuit in the
theaters or
you know you'd have to go someplace to
watch the fight
and then you'd pay like twenty dollars
to go to get into the fight
were you you weren't born when there was
closed circuit well all the other i just
started
when you thought closed circuit started
78
no i'd say early 70s yeah it's like 70
you know or probably the first the first
ali frazier fight 71
51 yep so and then it got bigger and
bigger and bigger
and then they were figuring out how to
deliver to the homes you know the
theaters and all this
so anyway aaron
bob aaron hired me and was great to me
then don hired me and so that's how i
really you know became a sportscaster
and
and uh there was no grand scheme or plan
or thought
just happened by happenstance that ali
came early and ali was great to me and
that was my first interview and ali you
know was honored me
all those years later he let me do his
last interview on
on television
in 2000 and we took we
we took america's greatest living
olympians so we took
muhammad ali ray leonard mary lou retton
and carl lewis carl lewis the most
decorated track and field mary lou
retton who would
revolutionize gymnastics in this country
with the 84 olympics
ray leonard who was an icon and then the
greatest ali and we went up to the
stamford pool
uh in uh in palo alto two nights before
michael phelps left
for the greek olympics in 2004 as before
he ever won a medal
and we bet that he would be the greatest
uh
swimmer of all time that he would break
mark spitz's record
have you ever met mark's bit yeah what's
the deal with him tell me about his
personality what's this we just finished
this so anyway that's
that that that show at the end of that
show all these last words
on television in that in that interview
we had a torch sent to us
from the uh athens olympic organizing
committee that's the one he had
yep and ali handed that torch and he
said i'm the greatest
you're the latest it's now up to you and
he handed that torch to michael phelps
and now michael phelps all these years
later
the most decorated gold medalist in the
history of the olympics
i think it's 18 gold medals 22 medals
overall
and now that show when you look at that
show you know
i don't think anything like that could
ever happen again the greatest athlete
ever
our greatest ali the greatest olympian
ever
in in in phelps and carl lewis to this
day still the most decorated track and
field athlete with
nine gold medals all those broad jumping
over four
olympics you know starting in los
angeles going to seoul
barcelona and atlanta so and mary lou
retton you know
kind of made popular after olga corbett
and nadia come in each
you know made gymnastics popular in
women's sports you know you can kind of
trace to her
making it a catapult so that was proud
of that show what was the question
i was talking to you about mark's best i
always heard rumors about him he was a
nice guy and this and that and he was
nice to me he was nice to me but he
turned down doing that show
he did not want to do that show because
he thought it would hurt him
commercially
really yeah it was the worst decision
ever made by any guy that
i mean why would you not want to be on
television with muhammad ali
mary lou retton carl lewis and
and and ray leonard and michael spitz i
mean it's like it's like
and michael phelps i mean it never made
any sense he thought it was going to
hurt his commerciality
he thought that it would somehow detract
from
i don't know i can't explain it but i
had i talked to him
30 times about the show he was always
very pleasant
but i could never get him to commit to
do it and eventually he just passed on
doing it and
it's kind of sad but it turns out
we didn't need him you know better off
we didn't have him now that we look back
on it
did you know jackie robinson no sir no i
know his wife
yeah she's great she's still alive yeah
wow but i remember
you know who else used to come into my
tails who
ray robinson really oh sugar ray
robinson all the time
oh yeah i don't know when he died he
probably died in 89 1989 i went to the
funeral
yeah he used to come in all the time
really talk to everybody and oh yeah
he drew a big crowd everybody wanted you
know they considered him the greatest
fighter ever
you know pound for pound why well listen
um
how could somebody eco handle that how
could what how could
my ego handle that being called the
greatest fighter of all time he's the
greatest fight i've ever seen how could
he handle that ego
how did he how could he live like that
wow that must have been some demons huh
you know what though
because he had losses yeah you know the
ego
is with the zero okay so like like look
at floyd floyd walks around 50-0
yeah okay wait a minute wait a minute so
so that
when you when when you're never defeated
then you know you think you never will
be defeated i know you are
rocky marciano i didn't know him but he
had a no after him too right
yes ray robinson never had that oh
so he knew what it was like to lose so
when he was called the greatest he could
say well you know what
that's your assessment may not be my
assessment because my assessment is i
know i lost how many times did he lose
oh he lost him 19 times okay so he lost
a lot
at a 202 fights knockout so
he knew what that felt like so anytime
somebody might say to him you're the
greatest he might say well
i'm going to accept that and thank you
but i know internally better i think you
still can't tell your story about him
please well somebody this is just a
story
this is just a small part of his career
why somebody's thinking
yes forever
and then he lost the fight to sugary i'm
not um jake lamotta
his first loss and then went like 79 and
now
or something without the loss
how do you do something and i'm thinking
that the guy looks so beautiful when if
he looks like perfection
he was tough and rugged like a dog
competitive you have to kill him to beat
him it's just really
it's marvelous entertainer just watching
them fight which is
awesome what do you think of this batch
of heavyweights
hey i think they have their purpose in
their generation
i think they all do i think since um
wilder and tyson fury had that
right yeah i think that fight um
cemented them and a generation of great
heavyweights
i really believe that's because deante
wilder's a great man yeah really
yep i don't know him you should here
you should yeah you should you should
take the time you should take the effort
and vice versa i believe i think not as
you said i
think i'll look at it from that
perspective yeah yeah because he's
worthy
yeah he's worthy and he's got you know
he's got a young child who's
spina bifida and so forth and you know
he's
been a terrific terrific father and i
think you're right and i think i i feel
that was
i think um anthony joshua and lance
lewis should talk
they have some kind of funny weird beef
right and and i think they know joshua
i've
met him it's really bad i don't like
that i think they should talk they
shouldn't be like that these two guys
don't you mention their name there huh
you know it's really not good
and tyson fury's an interesting subject
too oh he's an awesome guy though
yeah very interesting uh his about his
his background and
he you know i don't know how that guy
got up that was like
that was like unbelievable like that was
like frankenstein stuff
how did this guy get up off the carpet
that was incredible
but anyway but but
yeah um like these guys you know at
first i didn't but i started to
respect them after the last fight said
wow this is really awesome
that's good that's right that's good
boxing needs to have you involved
and for sure you you bring
you bring out in people memories of
that are fond to them
so your your involvement should be
important to you because it's important
to other people
and if you put an arm around some of
these fighters
and you give them your respect and your
time
i think it would really help the game
and really as opposed to
you know so much now everybody looks
back at their generation and says
you know what we were better
and they get resentful of the money that
these guys make and the attention they
get now but everything's changed social
media has changed television's changed
the delivery of it's changed
uh the dollars have changed you know
it's just it's just it's just crazy back
in your day when you were fighting for
all that money
people looked at you the same all these
generation and
and all those shaffers and all those
other guys looking at you and i said
well he couldn't beat me
they maybe didn't say it but they felt
it yeah they had to feel that right
because
you know but but i think we live in a
different time now
in a different era and um
i just think your participation
uh would mean a lot
you know because you're the guy you're
the guy they look at they're looking at
you on the video games they're looking
at you on youtube they're looking at you
all these knockouts and everything and
in many ways what they want to be
is be you but they can't be you but they
want to have
the ability to have your respect that
they can't have
but that's up to you
that's weird because you know when i was
a young kid that's all i wanted to do i
want darlee
and he said sugary and everybody around
to know my name and respect you
yeah i didn't care i just wanted to know
my name
you know i trained hard you know i
worked hard i used to go to their
restaurants and wait for them outside
the restaurants and stuff really
yeah and what and did they know your
name huh did they
no but i just watched them i just stalk
them and [ __ ]
that's why tell us the story what you
decided to put this uh tattoo on your
face
i don't know i'm i was supposed to do it
earlier put this hat i wanted a tattoo
on my face i was supposed to do it early
and i
i was gonna put a bunch of hearts and
[ __ ] on my face there's a bunch of
little hearts
and uh my friends are not i'm not gonna
do anything whack like that but i do my
heart's gonna be you know i mean
immortal i don't wanna do no way i'm not
gonna do whack quietly
so he said um let's let's think about
putting a tribal mark or something on
there and i said okay
we'll do that so like he called me in a
couple of days later he brought up this
tribal mark and so i said let's do it
and we did it
that's happened
you like looking at that yeah you're
happy i'm very happy
you didn't want any more no no i was
gonna do my whole faith at one time
i don't know if i want anymore it's a
possibility it'll hurt i might put a
toad on my heart
did it hurt attacking my face no that
didn't hurt my face that was my stomach
was really painful
why why was that painful i don't know
why it was it was just pain but that one
didn't hurt
none of my face were you high i'm
smoking
well okay so maybe that took down that
didn't some of the pain no because i was
smoking i did my stomach and it
didn't help no
you have any tats jim i don't no no tess
i never had that desire i've never
yeah no yeah so that's cool no i think
it's all fine whatever anybody wants to
do absolutely
cast any aspersions make any judgments
at all everything i let people know
how they want to live you know this is
how i you know what uh
they want to do is fine it's great i
want to change the world
you know jim i wanted to change the
world when people
they had to accept me who i was you know
if they want to be in my realm they want
to be my speech they want to accept me
they have to accept me who i was who i
wanted to be
did you ever just beat the hell out of
somebody excuse me did you ever out of
the ring did you ever just beat the heck
out of somebody just like
you just somebody just pissed you off
yeah yeah me
no oh come on i'm talking about did like
did you just like see somebody and you
and they did something they forget about
the suits or whatever
i mean did you just ever beat the heck
out of somebody and they just took their
medicine
yeah and what
tell us about it
i always just wondered is this some guy
down the street says something stupid to
you or some guy was in your presence in
an office or somebody just did something
dumb
and they got the wrath of the
heavyweight champion in the world that
they were actually on the receiving end
of that without a glove
listen um i never asked you that
question yeah i've hit a lot of people
in my life yeah
repercussions some sometimes in
different countries and stuff
i've hit a lot of people lawsuits yeah i
feel like but i mean how about just the
guy that just took his medicine that he
knew he did something wrong
and you beat him for it and he just took
it did you did that happen i'm sure it
happened i used to remember that
you know i remember um for one instance
um i was in um
like like if some people just have
fights you understand and they don't end
up in court over it it's because they
had a disagreement
always end up in court and stuff well
because they want
a payday yeah but i really did bad stuff
to himself
beat him up broke the cheeks and bones
or something
jim have you heard the story of mike's
first fight ever
in his life i don't think so when a kid
took his pigeon
yeah and killed my bird and some guy
killed my bird and stuff and i was
crying this holdery almost been nine to
ten how do you take your birth well i
had birds
um hidden somewhere in an abandoned
building
in a condemned apartment and somebody
told these kids from another
neighborhood where my birds went they
were going to steal my birds
and one guy snuck one of my birds out
and i had to chase and i said give my
bird back into no
fat [ __ ] [ __ ] you want this bird
he was black too but he called me a
black [ __ ] [ __ ] and he broke your
butt in half
she didn't rip the head off the bird
[ __ ] yeah
and then the guys that mike fight him
and afford him what happened that guy
i don't know what he is i beat him up
that day but i don't know what he's
doing somebody told me he was doing hard
times i would
love to see him and stuff you know his
name
gary flowers carries flowers scary
flowers
wow gary flowers
yeah that's amazing mike you remember
his name never forget him
wow never forget you know and and and
were you were you involved in boxing at
all yet
no never had a fight in my life okay and
and how much
longer after that did you go to fight
boxing and probably that sometime that
week i started somebody started um
giving me money to fight other kids from
other neighborhoods
oh and so you would beat up with the
kids another elsa would get beat up yeah
why would they beat you up because they
won the fight okay so so who would give
you the money
excuse me who would give you money um
older kid
he said you fight him and if you take
this and you take this then you'll fight
and how much was the money
dollar dollar five dollars something
like that
so this is the in the in in what year
i'm i'm taking seventy seventies okay
okay so you started who who recognized
you were good at this
other than the kids in the neighborhood
who recognized yourself people
keep there had to be some older kids the
younger kids saw the fight
and they told some people and someone
and the next day i know i saw this older
kid
came around with the kid that was at the
fight and another kid and that
other kid was for me to fight so i guess
the kid from the fight was telling the
older kid about me
and they brought this guy to the
neighbor so that's why that guy was
there with the older kid
and it's like lord of the flies yeah
yeah wow i can't believe i'm talking
about this and i thought wow i hate me
it's not for a minute that explained it
that this guy came with this other guy
the young guy told the older guy and the
older guy brought this guy over here
and that's the guy i was supposed to
fight because this guy told the older
guy about me
and how much older were they they were
like 15.
the oldest guy was probably 15. and you
were nine yeah
did anybody ever steal your pigeons
again yeah people stole my pigeons
because then that's not about
confronting you and stuff it's about
if you know they befriend you you go
somewhere you're not there oh i'm
talking about today ever
still at the time no nobody ever nobody
listen um
ever since that day i was known for
fighting people knew who i was
they respect me for fighting and stuff
in the neighborhood
did you know your father not well
i knew the man who they said my father
was
but you were never sure no
did you have a conversation with that
man yeah did you ask him was are you my
father yeah
what'd he tell you well i'm champion
well of course he'll say yes
i'm talking about before then never
before then never before then
i just took it if they say my father hey
dad
and that was it yeah you didn't want to
ask him any questions
no i did get to know him later and start
asking him questions and stuff
i'm not a question that really wanted to
know and answers i didn't really want
answers and stuff it was pretty it was
pretty grim stuff he was a pretty dark
guy and stuff is he alive no
how long ago he died he died in 92. did
he want anything from you
i don't know because i was offering it
too quickly and he never asked
i was offering it too quickly he never
had a chance to ask
was it weird for somebody to walk into
your life when you're a heavyweight
champion and say i'm your father
hey um
i wanted to be mean to him and stuff
you know but i wasn't angry at him
you weren't no were you thankful yeah i
was very grateful that he came back in
my life at that stage
not alone but he came back in my life
was very great i was very kind to him
he didn't have much to tell me you know
what was his name
his name was curly jimmy kirkpatrick
and did he maintain any relationship any
of the time with you with the woman who
was your mother
no no they didn't speak to each other
it's hand me over when they're finished
with me
your mother yeah and what was your
relationship like with her
she was loving but she was kind of
aggressive
never never i'm pretty much had um
never had a life together never pretty
much worked
wasn't afraid to really beat you hit me
with it hit you with anything pretty
much
i drank heavily and see what had a lot
of boyfriends
and stuff a lot of boyfriends and stuff
sometimes a boyfriend would come over
there and be drunk i would cut their
pockets and rob their money
that was just the world and how old how
old were you
when your mom died 16.
and that's when gus cuss took over and
well i knew cuz since i was 13 right
but i mean a major part of your life and
pretty much change and the people in the
catskills
well because she has she had pretty much
signed me wheeled me over like found me
over the course
before she died what was the lady's name
camille camille
yes and
she kind of took it from there yeah we
had to start when did they sign
you over i think i was
16 at the time 15. what's that feeling
like
excuse me what's that feeling like
your mom who you had known even though
she was abusive
and it hit you with a bunch of stuff and
just kind of said
take him i'm i'm done
i wanted to show the world who i was
when they were in the world know my name
what was your feeling when she passed
revenge
is that why you have that sign the best
way to show them is success or whatever
it says
no just um that's revenge when i say
revenge revenge was because we never had
anything we never had money we never had
food
we never had anything so my revenge was
half and everything
people know my name how often were you
hungry
a lot but uh you know when you
sometimes you get hungry your mind you
forget you're hungry you go to sleep
sometimes you know
people sometimes people say um you
sometimes
you can't sleep because you're so hungry
i think that was a lie when you're tired
you sleep don't care how hungry you are
that's how we run the streets all day
you know
my mother hopefully she from somewhere
somehow she'll get some money and bring
some money and food home don't know how
we're going to get but whatever you have
to do to get it you got it
let's take a break yeah man well we can
wrap that's
that's right this is just talking yeah
jim you being a such a close friend of
mike it makes it
you know you go for hours so hey man
thank you so much for coming
thank you yeah thank you mike you're
awesome man anytime
well mike great episode brother awesome
you know what you wanna do take us out
dude
all right everybody thanks for watching
another episode of hot boxing with mike
tyson i'm evan britton
i'm mike tyson i'm jim gray and jim gray
do they need to if you want anybody to
know where to get in touch with you how
to contact
you and contact mike okay all right
thanks guys
check us out through him subscribe on
our youtube channel hot boxing with mike
tyson subscribe on
itunes uh check us out everybody
thank you out of here peace look at the
[Music]
girls
[Music]